et faut-il reconfirmer ce n'est pas le
choix qu'a fait le gouvernement ce soir
il a choisi d'avancer le couvre-feu à 18
heures est ce que vous vous étiez pour
un confinement et pourquoi bonsoir il
est clair que sur un plan médical et
sanitaire la meilleure mesure où la
mesure la plus crédible pour arrêter la
propagation de l'épidémie
c'est le confinement généralisait donc
sur un plan médical et sanitaire c'est
la mesure la plus crédible si l'objectif
recherché est effectivement de faire
chuter les contaminations en dessous de
la fameuse barre des 5000 par jour pour
enfin pouvoir ré ouvrir les bars les
restaurants reprendre une vie culturelle
réouvrir les musées retourner au théâtre
et bien c'est une condition sinequanone
on a bien vu que le confinement
d'octobre qui était un confinement
allégé plus allégé qu'en mars n'a permis
de ramener le niveau des contaminations
qu'à 8000 par jour le couvre-feu qui
c'est y qui s'est poursuivie qui va être
généralisé à partir de samedi à partir
de 18 heures en fait n'est pas en mesure
d'atteindre l'objectif de contamination
inférieur à 5000 par jour on voit elle
continue de monter santé publique france
dit qu'aujourd'hui il y à 23000
nouvelles contaminations
bon j'ai noté que le premier ministre
n'avait compté lui que seize mille mais
elle sentait public rendant cette guerre
des chiffres dit bien 23000 donc sorti
du confinement du deuxième confinement
l'état 8000 contamination par jour
aujourd'hui on est à 23 24 milles par
jour
donc ça a triplé ces dons n'est donc pas
dans un plateau est bien dans une
dynamique positive
donc ça c'est un élément extrêmement
important malgré le couvre feu
et enfin en plus malheureusement on
découvre enfin le grand public découvre
ce que les médecins nous savions déjà
c'est à dire qu'on a affaire à une hydre
a donc une idée on affaire hacavie russe
qui en fait à plusieurs têtes
vous parlez des mutations les mutations
donc elles sont elles ont été toujours
très nombreuses mais comme toujours plus
il ya de cas plus il ya de mutation et
plus on risque d'avoir des mutations qui
ont un impact sur la population
qui s'avère est ce que vous êtes en
train d'annoncer qu'en fait ce
changement de couvre-feu c'est une étape
intermédiaire vers un an confie donc
vous juger inévitable
en tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est
que le couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures
dans toute la france à partir de samedi
ne sera pas une mesure suffisante
d'accord pour enrayer la propagation de
l'épidémie on peut s'étonner quand même
eric et avec tout le respect que je vous
dois le docteur on peut quand même
s'étonner que les médecins les plus
avisés qu'ils nous parlent des dégâts du
virus toute la journée
oubli nu de nous parler des dégâts sur
le cerveau humain sur la psychologie
humaine et pour la santé parle ont
cyniquement est strictement la santé
faisons pas de philosophie déplacer
extra du strict point de vue cynique de
la santé du point de vue du sanitat
risme le plus aveugle
je pense que la santé mentale des gens
est au moins aussi importante que leur
santé biologique pur